her candid new Memoir worthy she opened
up about an issue that has been kept
secret until
now there are so many surprising things
in the book but the thing that surprised
me the most that I actually had to
reread it because I said is this true
right was that in
2016 you and will decided that you were
going to live completely separate lives
it was not a divorce on paper right but
it was a divorce so from the year
2016 which is 7 years ago now yes y all
have
been aart
yeah but in public the couple who
married in
1997 denied the gossip about their
marriage this interview on Bravo's Watch
What Happens live with Andy Cohen was
taped a year after Will and Jada
separated how long have you guys been
together uh 23 years wow that's amazing
how do you keep it hot um how do I keep
it
hot [__] my son's best friend [__] my
husband imagine Tupac Shakur have my
husband live out the fantasy of slapping
men in front of me running the red table
talk as if I had a real open discussion
about my marriage and then being a fraud
the whole
time go in I don't know go in go I
haven't seen any of this no no but go in
over the several years Jada and will
kept up the appearance of a committed
married couple they even faced a scandal
When J had what she called an
entanglement with a family friend it's
not the friend of the
family it's the friend of the one dude
that was your
son okay if I have a
kid my kids's friends are not my friends
they're not friends of the family the
friends of my kids you're going to have
a play dat with Tommy Tommy tomm is not
my friend I mean they could be friends
of the family but Tommy's not my friend
you can't bang your your son's friend
that's the real problem I don't care if
cuz I know some families who take in
their you know their kids's friends as
almost their own kids or own family
that's fine you just can't bang
them I I never thought I would have to
say this but I guess I do as a parent
you can't ban your kids friends I mean
you T physically but it's all listen hey
we hearing that is one way of getting
out of the friend
zone I was AF of the family now I'm
banging the M forget that that's just
truly being a part of the family what
better way to ingratiate than make
babies Oh you part of this family yeah
I'm inside your
mom that's a wild bro neither let the
public know they had already split so I
guess my question
is I feel like you're a straight talker
I am
am you and I decided we were going to
take our space and what happened yeah
and then I got into an entanglement with
August Mrs
entanglement is a straight
talker bro is this a whole interview
satire is this run by the onion so why
do that like what was the reason I think
just not being ready yet still trying to
figure out between the two of us yeah
how to be in
Partnership right and in regards to how
do we present that to people you know
and we hadn't figured that out during
our walk in Baltimore Jada reflected on
their breakup why did the relationship
fracture oh why it fractur that that's a
lot of things and I think
all eyes on me that's why I mean people
say that but I doubt
it you think it's just another man no
it's not another man it's
her not fully being with will not
wanting that she said that in the first
place she didn't want that and then
after go ahead no go ahead finish so she
said that she didn't want that in the
first place I mean she's a straight
talker I got to take her word no she
said that not me but she's not straight
talker and irres of whatever she maybe
she has feel someone else where does the
[__] the friend the son's friend come
in where does the public embarrassment
come into all this stuff she got a lot
more problems than she's in love with
somebody else on the list of stuff that
she do or why it's not working I highly
doubt Tupac at the top I didn't say that
she was in love with someone else she
was just not in love with Will okay
doesn't matter not in love with whatever
it might be you said Tupac course so
that indicates it's somebody else sure
is that that's I'm just going what you
said but it's just like it's like it's
like it's someone that's it's not I
wouldn't call it love because it's
something that's really unattainable you
know what I mean but it's holding that
person to that unattainable standard
that is dead on top of that you know
what I mean the oh I wish it would have
been something else I wonder I wonder yo
being next to it I wonder what would
happen if it's [__] up you're not
justly in love with a person
but that person is looking behind your
mind let's put it that way most people
get married or get in relationships have
that what if with somebody else that's
not even necessarily always the issue
because as you get into a relationship
you settle into the groove of it that
excitement that thrill goes away you
think about that one person who just
gave you that feeling before and you you
you put the roast in classes the issue
with this lady and watching her
interviews or after anything happens is
what does she do to will I had an
entanglement she don't take
accountability she deflects blame she
puts it on other things she offis skates
everything at the top of the list of
reasons why they probably not together
somebody else is probably at the bottom
because there's a lot of things you
could work through sure you know the
whole Tupac thing is a funny meme
because of the fact that she said some
things and they've danc and like oh yeah
he's dead whatever and she said some
weird [__] I'm not going to lie the [__]
she said about Tupac I'm a fan she said
mess but me watching her behavior I'm
like I would look at all of those things
before the fact that she's in love with
some dead man coner you know coner me
watching that red table talk with her
and will that's divorce to me why would
you broadcast that thing but just the
things that she was saying during that
interview by the time we got to 2016 we
were just exhausted with trying I think
we were both kind of still stuck in our
fantasy of what we thought the other
person should be you know what it really
sounds like every time she talk she says
we but it feels like she someone's not
tired of trying when they get up on
stage and slap a man for disrespecting
his wife who hasn't been with him for 6
years that don't sound like somebody
who's done with trying does that sound
like to you no somebody make a joke out
a wor on you go up and slap that person
does that someone like someone you
giving up on the marriage I think in
that video I think in in that video that
we when we covered that I said that it
just looked like a whole lot of he's
going through it yeah he's going through
it yeah he's still calling her my wife
when she saying keep my wife's name out
your when you say it like that he was
trying to game Power at that time that's
what it looked like you're trying to get
he's losing grip on something he was
going through it it all makes sense and
she's like yeah nah he still didn't he
still give didn't give up but at some
point you got you got to give it up the
person is disrespecting you all day
every day and all night in the social
media in the media going to talk about
you stop if you're over it you're making
mileage with the names the the dude's
name Jada says she considered a legal
divorce but could never go through with
it I made a promise that there will
never be a reason for us to get a
divorce we will work through m whatever
and I just haven't been able to break
that
promise but you still live separately
live
separately it's weird you still yeah we
live separately it's it's off this is
what I think what you think I think will
looks like a chump that's all I think
unfortunately will went from that man to
like never want to be that man in my
later years say that again will went
from my younger years being that man to
never want to be that man my I I look at
will and he just looks so pathetic to me
and the fact that he went up on stage
and slapped somebody over some lame joke
okay right over a woman who ain't even
really his [__] other dudes
disrespecting him all the time we'll
just look like a
chunk look like a chunk that's all it
comes down to I could have seen
something happen like where it would be
reconciliation but after this I I'm in
I'm putting myself in the shoes of Chris
frck and I'm like I'm writing a new
special you SLA me over what yeah Will
slapped me over our
wife our Collective wife she for the
streets now we've been do she what she
been through this separation you but you
SLA me over what our wife you slap me
over the fact
that you know what this
is hey this is whenever you go out with
a girl and you go to the restaurant and
her ex shows up and it's like who who's
this dude and she like yo my God we've
been broken up since like two years ago
nah man you mine you m that's how
pathetic it is I I don't it's even worse
than that you know what it's like it's
like when you in a group of friends and
somebody roast you in that group of
friends but they too big so you don't
want to fight with them so the next
person that laughs you start fighting
them they didn't make the joke right the
one who really stabbed you was a per but
you can't fight with them so you fighted
somebody who laughs why just cuz you
don't want to adhere or deal with
whatever that's what it look like you
didn't yeah I cuz he can't beat up he
can't slap J you can't slap J you can't
throw ends with she can't can't slap
Tupac you can't you can't throw hands
with August you can't throw hands with
and he was intimidated with by Tupac
that's what he said his words while he's
talking about what a run quick C you're
like getting jiggy with it I know you're
not going to slap the man right so yeah
yeah again yeah that's crazy clown but
you said it the best you said it the
best he went
from think about who he was when we were
growing up he was in the coolest movies
he was doing songs that not everybody
liked but everybody still got jiggy with
it you hear me right people loved his
character on Fresh prins they loved him
in the movies a bad boy he had the body
he had everything everybody's looking at
him he had a pristine life in the
background doing charity work everybody
was looking at him like he's that dude
and come to find out you look behind the
curs and the dude is basically a cuck
he's nio
2.0 that [__] crazy to me it is so it is
how do I feel about the man I don't know
I don't know what to say about this guy
it's just sad as far as she goes she is
what she is that's crazy cuz and now you
don't understand why them kids are so
weird how can they not be you know what
I'm going say this too Willow and Jaden
for the weird environment they had to
grow up in came out very good yeah they
good well will was oldest is not nowhere
near that because that's not with who he
had but yeah so we'll see when the full
interview comes up there's anything more
interesting but that's all I got
anything else you want to say I just
wish that she she shut the [__] up with
that Jay stop talking she trying to make
some money I know she's trying to make
some D Duck get money but it's like you
you you you did enough it's cool we we
like no absolutely not she married a
chump she should make as much money off
that chump good for her so these chumps
learn stop yeah you know what put out a
tell all book say his dick game is weak
say whatever you got to say so that
anybody watches this never tolerate this
kind of behavior again I'm of the
opposite mindset of preach I hope she
destroys Will Smith yeah don't half ass
it cuz I don't ever want to see this
kind of garbage again from any other
individual will'll th to the Wolves at
this point that's how I feel I see what
you're saying I disagree but I see what
you're saying but yeah no hey he chose
her you I understand he made his bed he
got lie in it Jesus s hey well he he
doesn't lie in it everybody else is well
I saw him slap Chris Rock that's him
lying in
it I'm saying yeah yeah I got your joke
okay yeah yeah everybody's lying in it
no but he's lying in the bed too you
just watch
it can you watch that August come
through his crib be like hey you want
something for breakfast like nah I just
got done piping your wife that's crazy
that's crazy